plucked from stormy Mediterranean Seas
this week these young men have escaped
the fighting in Sudan
this southernmost Italian island is
braced for a potentially record-breaking
summer of Migrant arrivals
the Sudanese sailed from Tunisia where
there's a sophisticated and profitable
smuggling Network
not willing there'll be much more work
compared to the past this Smuggler tells
us
last year more than a hundred thousand
migrants crossed the central
Mediterranean according to the European
Union
I've organized a lot of trips where
things didn't go as expected because the
boat was overweight and that's why so
many die there were no life vests or
inner tubes a hundred people lost their
lives in two trips
lamb produces migrant Holding Center
managed by a local Cooperative has
struggled to handle the large volume of
arrivals so now the Red Cross is taken
over with plans to provide a more
professional and Humane service it's in
charge of us to re-enture them and tell
them that they are safe because from
there they rise we realize that we they
need the people that say to them they
are you are finally safe the Smugglers
say they're also improving their
operations
you see to stop the loss of life we've
reorganized how we work we've got rid of
the risks that might cause a boat to
sink before we didn't have people who
could read a compass now we look to
assign a captain who knows how to use
one and we don't overload boats anymore
it's all safety first
those who make it now face a more
hostile reception from Italy's
nationalist government newcomers will
find it much harder to get a two-year
special protection residency permit if
they don't qualify for full Asylum
prime minister Georgia Maloney won power
last year promising to crack down on
boat migrants Human Rights Watch calls
Italy's new immigration law repressive
and inhumane it's intended to dissuade
migrants from coming here it's not
having any effect more than 45 000
people have arrived in Italy since the
start of this year it was 12 000 in the
same period last year
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera lampedusa Italy